rainbow toads Baby Bros and even some
references that are truly out of this
world ready for the Easter eggs you
missed in the Super Mario Brothers movie
Let's Go
the Super Mario Brothers movie opens
with a brutal attack by Bowser's forces
on the ice kingdom of the Penguins the
Penguins themselves are classic Mario
characters first appearing in the genre
defining Super Mario 64. but it's
Bowser's Army of dangerous bad guys who
steal the spotlight in this scene all
manner of Koopa troopas are present red
shelled and green-shelled variants
paratroopas spinies and many more the
Magikoopa known as kamik leads the Army
serving as Bowser's second in command
throughout the rest of the movie a vast
menagerie of classic Mario baddies
parades across the screen Luigi battles
a horde of Undead Dry Bones who fall
apart and reassemble with Eerie clicks
just like in the games Bowser's prison
guards Patrol his lair in flying Koopa
clown cars which Cranky Kong references
by telling them to keep their clown
claws off of him later in the film there
are Hammer brothers and Goomba Stacks
cheap cheaps bloopers and of course some
bombs for good measure there are so many
familiar Mario enemies that even Bowser
can't keep all of their names straight
in one scene where he addresses his army
he calls out a group of spinies and
fails to remember what they're called to
be fair they're pretty forgettable
whatever those things are oh our
introduction to the Mario Brothers comes
in the form of a goofy commercial shot
in the style of local small business
spots it shows Mario and Luigi wearing
their iconic outfits and talking in over
the top Italian-American accents one
moment shows them flying with yellow
capes tied around their necks
referencing the ones used to fly in
Super Mario World and reflect attacks in
these Super Smash Brothers series while
never Central to the mainline games this
background lore of the Mario Brothers as
brooklyn-based plumbers is a
long-standing staple of the franchise
the first iteration of the Super Mario
Brothers Plumbing Company appeared in
the Super Mario Brothers Super Show
another iteration pops up in the 1993
film in which the brothers drive a van
similar to the one seen in the new movie
even the Mario Brothers status as down
on their luck plumbers can be seen as a
reference to these past iterations in
both the Super Show and the 1993
live-action movie Mario and Luigi
grapple with tight company budgets and
stiff competitions after the Super Mario
Brothers Plumbing commercial ends we
zoom out to find the real Mario and
Luigi hanging out in a Brooklyn Pizzeria
the sign outside identifies it as Punch
Out Pizza a reference to Nintendo's
beloved boxing franchise inside the
restaurant you can see framed pictures
of many of the kooky fighters from the
punch out series including first rounder
glass Joe tough guy bald bull and
protagonist Little Mac punch out isn't
the only game referenced in the pizzeria
there's also an arcade cabinet featuring
what appears to be 1981's Donkey Kong
Mario's first official game however the
art on the side of the machine instead
identifies it as Jump Man Mario's name
in the English instructions for the
original Donkey Kong one of the deeper
cut references in the Super Mario
Brothers movie comes in the form of
Spike Mario and Luigi's former boss who
torments them at Punch Out Pizza Spike
wears a hat with the words wrecking crew
emblazoned on it which seems to be just
the name of his construction company but
this is actually a clever callback to
Mario's early days Wrecking Crew is a
sub-series of the Mario franchise that
began with an arcade game released in
1984 playing off of the success of
Donkey Kong the two-player version of
the game features Mario and Luigi on
various action-packed construction site
levels in the NES version of Wrecking
Crew The Brothers must also contend with
an antagonist named Foreman Spike who's
clearly the inspiration for the movie
character Spike also shows up in
Wrecking Crew 98 a Japanese exclusive
super famicom title this Easter Egg
Works on multiple levels spike is upset
in the movie because Mario and Luigi
quit his company to start their own this
can be read as a joke about how the
Mario series became far more popular
than the original Wrecking Crew game or
him was a carpenter back in his Donkey
Kong days before switching careers and
becoming a plumber many fans expressed
frustration with Chris Pratt's casting
as Mario in the Super Mario Brothers
movie and there are still those who
would prefer a different voice actor had
been selected specifically Charles
martinet he's the actor who has voiced
Mario Luigi Waluigi and Wario in every
major game since the 1990s hello I'm
amario let's make a pizza pie together
you go get some massage I'm gonna get
some spaghetti we put spaghetti in the
sausage and pizza while Martinez
certainly doesn't have as big a role in
the new movie as Pratt he does offer his
talents to two supporting characters a
character credited as Giuseppe seen
playing Jumpman in the pizzeria at the
start of the movie and briefly at the
end is voiced by Martin a in this role
he gets to put his own incomparable spin
on some classic Mario lines and sounds
capping off the movie with his iconic
Wahoo martinet also voices Mario and
Luigi's father while this second
character doesn't have as many
recognizable Mario sound bites it is
clever and wholly appropriate casting
after all martinet has been the one
responsible for bring bringing both
characters to life for decades it's me
Mario
hello
Mario's movie bedroom is a treasure
Trove of Nintendo Easter eggs the most
obvious one is the NES he has hooked up
to his TV on which we see him playing a
Kid Icarus sadly he dies pretty quickly
in the game Conjuring the game's
Infamous I'm finished game over screen
this is far from the only reference
though on top of his TV you
are wing
owned by the main characters of the Star
Fox games numerous other retro Nintendo
games are called out in the various
posters that cover Mario's walls one
with the word Falcon printed on it
features a picture of the Blue Falcon a
vehicle flown by Captain Falcon in the
futuristic f-zero racing games another
poster that just says cool has a picture
of an upright polar bear wearing
sunglasses an enemy from the NES game
ice climber other NES games that the
posters appear to reference include Kung
Fu and Spy Hunter given that Mario is
the most famous Nintendo character it
only makes sense that his room is filled
with references to the company's other
games
Mario is pulled out of his bedroom by a
TV news alert that shows rampant
flooding in Brooklyn on the broadcast
you can see a version of Mayor Pauline a
character with a rich history in the
Mario franchise attempting to calm the
public while speaking to a reporter
Pauline actually goes back as far as
Mario himself as it's her not Princess
Peach who must be rescued in the
original Donkey Kong arcade game she
also returns as a character in the Mario
vs Donkey Kong games in the Nintendo
switch hit Super Mario Odyssey Pauline
enters the modern franchise timeline as
the mayor of New donk City a Mario fight
version of the Big Apple in most of her
incarnations Pauline wears red and has
dark hair her usual dress is swapped out
for a striking red pantsuit while
performing mayoral duties in Odyssey and
it's this particular version of the
character who's seen on TV in the Super
Mario Brothers movie when Mario and
Luigi tried to help with the flooding
situation in Brooklyn they wind up
getting pulled down into a very deep and
very old part of the New York sewers
it's there that they come upon the
iconic green warp pipe that pulls them
into the Mushroom Kingdom this part of
the sewers can be seen as an Easter egg
in itself as it evokes the setting of
the original Mario Brothers arcade game
that succeeded Donkey Kong in the story
of that game Mario and Luigi are fixing
problems in the New York City sewers
when they're suddenly attacked by
various monsters that emerge from Green
pipes it's an appropriate location to
start their Adventure being inspired by
the game that officially kicked off the
Mario franchise
anyone who's played a Mario game knows
that Luigi is kind of a coward Luigi's
penchant for fear was spun out into the
Luigi's Mansion series of games which
gets its own little reference in the
Super Mario Brothers movie
from Death when Luigi first arrives in
these so-called dark lands he finds
himself in a spooky Forest haunted by
dry bones while there are no actual
ghosts or mansions in sight we do get a
couple of direct nods to those games
Luigi's constant fidgeting with his
flashlight is pulled straight from his
games as is the quivering way he keeps
calling his brother's name
the first few minutes after Mario
arrives in the Mushroom Kingdom are
packed with references and Easter eggs
in addition to Toad and the many giant
mushrooms the forested area Mario lands
in has some specific polls from the
games Mario encounters multiple bitty
buds bug-like Critters known for
traveling in groups there's also a large
Bram ball sporting a recognizably dour
expression once Mario and Toad get into
town the Mushroom Kingdom references
really start to pop up there are coin
blocks that toads use like ATMs there
are moving platforms power-up icons and
the clear warp pipes from Super Mario 3D
World in one shot you can see the
Marquee of a crazy cap store from Super
Mario Odyssey in another there's an
antique shop filled with old school
items including p-switches music boxes
magical potions and more one toad is
shown carrying a cheap Jeep in a plastic
bag like a pet fish there's even a nod
to a common tactic for getting old NES
cartridges to work
and of course Peach's castle is the
Crown Jewel the general look and layout
of the palace stay true to the video
games and there are even some paintings
of distant lands straight from Super
Mario 64. one of the most iconic parts
of the mainline Super Mario games is the
world map it takes different forms and
different installments but the idea
stays the same it's a visual
representation of the various lands
kingdoms or galaxies Mario must Traverse
in the Super Mario Brothers movie we get
multiple instances of the world map one
appears in Peach's Throne Room another
more traditional map of the same
kingdoms appears later in Donkey Kong's
house even though the movie doesn't
spend a ton of time in every one of the
familiar areas from the games we do get
glimpses of most of them Mario Peach and
Toad journey through several in a single
Montage visiting the floating inverted
pyramids of a desert land the foggy
Cliffs of a sky Kingdom a grassy world
with a Super Mario 64 Cannon and even
Yoshi's Island which as you might expect
is filled with Yoshi's sure power-ups
may be the main source of Mario's
strength in the video games but he and
his allies also have some innate
abilities that are always available to
them these are also represented in the
Super Mario Brothers movie Princess
Peach showcases some classic Mario moves
while acing the training level she puts
Mario through watch and learn
these include while jumping bouncing off
of bullet bills to gain extra height and
floating gracefully to slow her aerial
descent a technique that is unique to
Peach across many Mario games later
while battling Bowser's Minions with
Donkey Kong during the film's climax
Mario executes a Flawless ground pound
it's these little touches that show the
attention to detail that went into the
Super Mario Brothers movie and the whole
film is a lot more fun for fans to watch
because it includes them
there are so many beloved Super Mario
games that putting some above others can
feel like an impossible task however the
Super Mario Galaxy games are definitely
in the upper echelon and the Super Mario
Brothers movie seems to agree there are
numerous references to the Wii games
throughout the film the most obvious is
lumily the unsettlingly cheerful and
nihilistic character seen in Bowser's
dungeon in the Mario Galaxy Games Loomis
are a star-shaped race of friendly
cuties who Aid Mario on his journey
lumili is the name used for a specific
variety of luma in the games who sell
Mario items in exchange for Star Bits a
kind of currency lumili isn't the only
Galaxy reference when Mario and Luigi
are trying to fix a sink near the
beginning of the movie one of their rich
clients can be seen reading a book
entitled Galaxy the book has a picture
of one of the game's tiny planets on it
later Peach appears to make an all but
explicit allusion to the series there's
a huge Universe out there
more
of a lot of galaxies there are a lot of
toads in the Mushroom Kingdom but some
stand out more than others the Super
Mario Brothers movie features all the
different colors of toad that fans will
be familiar with from the games as well
as a couple with a bit more main
character energy unsurprisingly the
first of these is the main toad voiced
by Keegan Michael key though he's only
ever referred to as toad in the film he
has the huge backpack reminiscent of
everyone's favorite Treasure Hunter
Captain Toad first appearing in the
Super Mario Galaxy Games Captain Toad
has since become a staple and the
primary toad of the franchise he even
got his own Standalone game perhaps if
there's another Mario movie Down the
Line the first films toad could
officially be granted the rank of
Captain the other notable toad in the
Super Mario Brothers movie is the
bespectacled advisor to Princess Peach
this character would seem to be a
stand-in for toadsworth the elderly
Butler toad who acts as Peach's Aid in
many of the games however the look of
the movie character is all wrong aside
from the glasses and General toad shape
the two have nothing in common where
toadsworth has brown spots a beard and a
walking stick the character in the movie
is a purplish blue and seems much
younger his look is much more similar to
that of hint Toad from the modern games
and both characters likely served as
inspiration
to drive home just how protective Mario
has always been of his little brother we
get a cute flashback scene of Luigi
building a castle with blocks as a
little tyke when a bully comes over and
smashes it Mario leaps in to fight the
villain off and cheer his bro up it's a
cute moment that also lets the movie
pull in the Baby Mario and Baby Luigi
designs from the games though they're
technically just younger versions of the
brothers Baby Mario and Baby Luigi have
practically become independent
characters in their own right they've
starred in their own games like Yoshi's
Island and co-starred with their older
selves in 2005's Mario and Luigi
partners in Time in the Mario Kart
franchise and some Mario sports games
the babies are separate selectable
characters the movie also gives us a
brief look at baby Peach and her
mysterious arrival in the Mushroom
Kingdom like Baby Mario and Baby Luigi
Baby Peach is an independent character
in several games
one of the more Curious additions to
Bowser's character in the Super Mario
Brothers movie is his penchant for
musical performance on two separate
occasions we see Old King Koopa tickling
the ivories and belting out a love
ballad for Princess Peach while not
exactly an Easter egg this seems like a
clear nod to voice actor Jack Black's
long career as a musician in the comedy
Rock Duo Tenacious D there is a more
specific Mario related Easter egg in
these scenes however the grand piano
Bowser plays on has Ludwig von Koopa
inscribed on it in the games Ludwig is
the oldest member of the Koopalings
named of course after Ludwig von
Beethoven
what would a Super Mario movie be
without power-ups fortunately we don't
have to find out as the new film is full
of them multiple characters including
Peach and Donkey Kong use fire flowers
Peach uses an ice flower to freeze
Bowser in the final battle Mario's first
power-up of course is a regular super
mushroom ironic given his distaste for
them in the movie as in the games the
mushroom makes him bigger and stronger
the first thing he does after eating one
is to break a brick block which is a
nice touch because those blocks are only
breakable in the games when you're Super
Mario in his battle with Donkey Kong
Mario becomes Cat Mario a newer power-up
from the games like in Super Mario 3D
World Cat Mario has better reflexes
sharp claws and a powerful dive bomb
attack which he uses to finish off DK
for the final battle Mario gets his
famous Tanooki Suit upgrade from Super
Mario Brothers 3. this power up allows
him to fly and use a tail whip attack
different characters referred to him as
both a raccoon and a bear in this form
which is a subtle nod to the power-ups
origin inspired by the Japanese raccoon
dog the Tanuki suit is a slight upgrade
over the raccoon Mario power-up in the
games
though Bowser is the main villain of the
Super Mario Brothers movie we do get a
decent bit of the even older rivalry
between Mario and Donkey Kong Mario
battles Kong to win the Kong Army to
Peach's side and their duel takes place
in an arena that evokes the construction
sites in the original Donkey Kong there
are some deeper Cuts here too in the
games Cranky Kong is canonically the
Donkey Kong from the original Donkey
Kong his son in that timeline is Donkey
Kong Jr the star of the sequel of the
same name the Donkey Kong fans know and
love from the Donkey Kong Country series
is technically Cranky's grandson but the
movie smartly simplifies This genealogy
by making the main DK cranky son instead
regardless it's fitting for cranky to be
present at the fight given that he was
the first one to ever face off against
Mario in the games
while he's most famous for his own games
Mario has become similarly well known
for his appearances in the popular Super
Smash Brothers series appropriately some
recognizable moves from those games also
make their way into the Super Mario
Brothers movie Mario uses a swinging
jump punch move multiple times most
notably in his training montage against
a cardboard cutout Bowser this move has
been part of his smash kit for decades
in the form of his forward aerial attack
Donkey Kong also uses some of his own
smash attacks in his fight with Mario
including his down special which sees
him repeatedly slapping opponents on the
ground beneath him he also lets loose
with his forward smash attack which
takes the form of a giant clap Mario
also uses his patented super jump punch
and DK showcases his giant punch at
different points to round out their
attacks Cranky Kong and Donkey Kong are
the main Kongs in the Super Mario
Brothers movie but they aren't the only
ones during DK's duel with Mario you can
see a number of other characters from
the Donkey Kong Country games cheering
their pal on Diddy Kong Dixie Kong and
Chunky Kong are all sitting next to each
other for the event and Diddy even gets
called out by name later Funky Kong is
seen driving a cart behind Mario on
Rainbow Road Donkey Kong's first
appearance is also set to the DK rep
which his fans in the crowd appear to be
singing the goofy tune first appeared in
Donkey Kong 64 and a more upbeat version
plays on the Super Smash Brothers Melee
stage Congo jungle the whole jungle
Kingdom area in the movie pulls heavily
from the Donkey Kong Country games the
Kong's Seaside Huts adorned with
hammocks and packed with bananas appear
in numerous entries in the series
Mario Kart might be the most popular
sub-series of the Super Mario franchise
so it only makes sense for it to play a
major role in the movie in order to tie
the concept of super powered go-karts
into the rest of the story the film
makes the carts Central to Kong society
which works pretty well Mario Peach and
Toad get to design their own carts in
the Kong's massive garage which is
filled with specific nods to the games
in addition to the music the characters
build their carts using three slider
Wheels to select a base wheels and
glider this is very similar to how you
construct a cart in the most recent
Mario Kart games Mario's ride is a
slight variation on his classic red cart
from the games Peach does her biker suit
from the series to ride a matching pink
motorcycle first introduced in Mario
Kart Wii the race scenes also pull in
lots of Maneuvers from Mario Kart such
as hopping into drifts glider sections
and zero gravity segments that utilize
hover Wheels Mario even does a track
skip shortcut at one point characters
attack each other with banana peels
green shells and the always dreaded blue
well and of course the entire Koopa
Chase sequence takes place on Rainbow
Road the most famous track from the
games that appears in every installment
in addition to the more regular baddies
like Koopa troopas and Goombas the Super
Mario Brothers movie features some
bigger foes from the franchise after
getting blown off of rainbow road Mario
and Donkey Kong Land in the water and
are devoured by a giant red eel known as
a mare in the games the massive
creatures first appeared in Super Mario
64 and have been a staple ever since
near the end of the film Bowser launches
a bomber build to destroy the Mushroom
Kingdom which Mario cleverly destroys
known as Bonsai bills in the games these
giant bullet Bills first popped up and
started tormenting Mario and Super Mario
World their huge size makes them more
common in the series 2D outings where
you can't Dodge them by simply moving to
the side the bomber bill in the film
appears to be an upgraded version as it
homes in on Mario with frightening
accuracy Mario isn't exactly a franchise
that's known for its dialogue but the
movie still manages to fit in a bunch of
iconic lines the red plumber lets fly
with plenty of instances of Wahoo Mamma
Mia and it's amazing as do the
characters voiced by Charles martinet
let's go and here we go also show up the
latter spoken by Peach instead of Mario
this time around then there are the meme
lines when Mario first tries to enter
Princess Peach's castle to talk to her
the toad guards refused to let him in
they say quite sarcastically our
princess is in another Castle this
Echoes the infamous line from the
original Super Mario Brothers and of
course Donkey Kong insists during his
fight with Mario that it is on like
Donkey Kong an adage that's never spoken
in the games but has nonetheless become
immediately recognizable
Mario's bedroom decorations aren't the
only references to other Nintendo games
in the Super Mario Brothers movie the
film's version of Brooklyn is loaded
with retro Easter eggs including a car
wash with the balloon fight kit on the
sign a travel agency referencing Super
Mario Sunshine and a truck with original
Nintendo star Mr Game and Watch on the
side there are also a few different
references to duck hunt in the movie one
restaurant glimpsed in the background of
the Brooklyn scenes is called shazukanar
which roughly translates from French as
duck hunting then there's the
temperamental dog named Francis who
attacks Mario and Luigi early in the
movie while clearly a different breed
Francis is the same color as the
similarly infuriating Duck Hunt dog and
could be meant as a reference
alternatively Francis could be an
allusion to Shigeru miyamoto's Infamous
encounter with an angry chained up dog
which gave him the idea for Mario's
chain chomp enemy games aren't the only
Nintendo products referenced in the
Super Mario Brothers movie there are
also a number of Easter eggs tied to the
company's various game systems during
the Mario vs Donkey Kong battle one Kong
can be seen wearing a 64 t-shirt in the
crowd a nod to the Nintendo 64. earlier
when Luigi's green cell phone starts to
ring fans May recognize the ringtone as
a variant of the GameCube startup jingle
one of the more bizarre references is a
store called discune whose sign Bears a
cute floppy disk shaped character this
is an odd to discune the mascot of
Nintendo's famicom disc system console
of course the biggest console Easter egg
in the movie is Mario's original
Nintendo Entertainment System on which
he plays Kid Icarus the blocky gray box
and controllers are Faithfully recreated
but it's sad to know he can't play Super
Mario Brothers on the system the Super
Mario Brothers movie takes a lot of
story Beats from Super Mario Odyssey
including Bowser's plan to force
Princess Peach to marry him for the
wedding he wears the same flashy white
tuxedo and Top Hat combo seen in that
game and he also offers her the same
terrifying bouquet made of tiny piranha
plants you might notice a few
distinguished guests if you peek into
the pews just before the wedding begins
King babam the first boss in Super Mario
64 and a later staple of the Mario Party
series is seen advancing up the aisle to
a seat near the front when he sits down
he accidentally bumps into a green Koopa
shell and causes it to bounce back and
forth between him and the side of the
bench this is a clever reference to the
perpetual motion of green shells in the
Mario Kart series also present is King
Boo wearing his own shiny crown and a
sledge bro a hulking Hammer Brother
variant from the games clearly Bowser
invited all of his closest friends
the Super Mario Brothers movie ends with
a climactic battle between Mario Luigi
and Bowser back in Brooklyn after some
warp pipe Shenanigans the two brothers
embrace the power of the Superstar to
unlock immense power just as in the
games they become invincible after
touching the star allowing them to
defeat King Koopa and his lackeys with
ease the star music plays in the
background and they even do the arms
outrun Mario performs in the newer games
well powered up
all right that's a girl not everything
about this final scene is quite accurate
to the source material though if you've
played the games you'll know that a
star's invincibility makes it impossible
to bounce off of enemies instead Mario
and friends simply crash right through
them Mario and Luigi are still able to
jump off of some bullet bills in the
climax battle in the movie though some
enemies are simply more powerful and
this version of Mario's world